[Musik]
[Applaus]
die verhöre jetzt soeben gelaunt
allerdings nicht um das soeben raus
gekommene neue merchandise aus lucka -
shop.de gehen denn ich darf euch heute
herzlich willkommen heißt und seiner
neuen episode was geht was macht dir ich
habe deine youtube angeschaut immer mit
minecraft und somit minecraft wir das
ist schon vorher träger das ist unnormal
lang her oder so ist es bei euch so
dunkel
warum er sieht über den ich geschaut
absolute ehre
ich spreche ich mit dem fußballplatz
oder
gutes gespräch
[Musik]
hallo wir hatten heute irgend jemanden
grüßen oder so glücklichen alter mega
korrekt ist so lieb von euch freuen dass
kaugummi verschluckt weihnachtsbaum
hinten ja schön leicht über meinen
weihnachtsbaum zeigen
[Musik]
da kommt ihr so richtig berlin drin oder
so berlin aber ihr seid eine stunde
außerhalb
na wie geht's dir guten die da machen
wir uns schon mal gesehen auf mtv durch
die wand cockpit dazu bekannt ob ich
glaube du bist ja nicht die einzige mit
einer weißen weste gegen die man
genießen
ich grüße dich war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja ich wollte jetzt nicht geben ich erst
mal in die top leute ich habe nun keine
getroffen
[Musik]
was machst du gerade was und wie du ja
soll ich in welchem hatte kommt eine
frau beim arzt
ich konnte ganz knapp auch nicht ich
habe noch nie so ein schönes gesicht
gesehen das ist wahnsinn
ich nehme noch ein bild machen ja klar
logisch ich bin krank du bist im schrank
warum bis zu einem schrank okay ich bin
kein geschwistern im schrank
[Musik]
warum stehst du im schrank schätze nicht
warum
[Musik]
okay wir sehen uns hallo ich bin rapper
hobby ist mein cooler onkel
[Musik]
ist mein bruder hubert ins studio warum
sonst habe ich im mikro nahles habe ich
hab' ich habe ich hab ich eine stunde
später hier guck da ist will aber nicht
dass nicht google
doch ob ich habe ja lange heiße ich da
kommt er aus frankfurt zufällig ihr seid
ihr die frankfurter jungs jetzt aber
keine scheiße ganz kurz ja ich habe mich
letztens habe ich als jockey war habe
ich zwei jungs getroffen
die haben hier einfach beleidigt die
meinten die kommen aus frankfurt und die
frankfurter jungs kommen aus berlin
wo seid ihr gerade in der schule oder
oder was das von der decke dass die
zwischendecke ihr seid in der schule
eher jungs ist es samstagmittag warum
seid ihr in der schule das ist nur das
waren 100 prozentig die frankfurter
jungs da ich könnt ihr euch noch daran
erinnern ich habe vor einigen tagen
wochen auf die zwei jungs getroffen die
mich beleidigt haben macht die feuerwerk
wir sind frankfurter jungs
das waren die
und die habe ich auch die ganzen hobbs
genommen jetzt das waren die frankfurter
jungs
ich will jetzt schon die ganze zeit
irgendwas geredet ja was geht was macht
ihr gar so dass immer wundervoll wenn
man mit seinem regal dann
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gutes internet was ihr habt wie ich auf
youtube heiße montana black 88 ja ja
genau das bin ich habe mehrere kanäle
einfach nicht weggedrückt allerdings
seiner lieben freunde will ich an der
stelle das heutige video ist auch
beenden wenn euch mal wieder irgendwie
mit luca ich will noch mal das intro
hören mit solch gefallen hatte lasse
gerne einen daumen hoch unter video ihr
da schreibt mir die kommentare was ich
in meiner nächsten abend wie folge
machen soll
soll ich die leute mal verarschen weil
wieder pranken in schwarzen machen
anmachsprüche keine ahnung was schreibst
und in die kommentare abonnieren einen
kanal weil es noch keinen teil von der
luxus- seit mehr als die hälfte dass ich
meine videos angucken haben ein kanal
nicht abonniert und dieses merchandise
kam heute online im lucas ab also schaut
er auch gern vorbei
[Musik]